yeah yeah
oh man dude i wasn't even ready for how
great this was gonna be dude
flavor flav
i mean
this one's just hilarious all the way
through enjoy and
let's get into it this is the van life
there this is the van life wild ride
wow
i like that i like that sign well thanks
man we made it green because [ __ ] dude
you're bawling out here in bel air
huh
here you go you ready to go i'm trying
whenever you're ready all right this is
how we do it
ladies and gentlemen
flavor flav yeah dude
now have you met my co-host scott
randolph we met like that's your
question yeah
did we start yet
we did i just did when i announced you
you did yeah
oh snap do me a favor yeah
do it again all right you got it
[Laughter]
ladies and gentlemen flavor flake yeah
gee that's right g only way to go i'm on
a stevo show
what's up steve
i'm doing great man and you know scott
randolph what's up what's going on man
i'm good scott how you doing scott i'm
living life my last name is randolph
yeah hey you know what i got a homie
right one of my best best friends man
you know i'm saying the name eric his
last name happens to be randolph that's
right you know i'm saying that my son
karma you know his daughter is you know
is his best friend they've been best
friends since kindergarten
that's the randolphs yeah so so so
you're in good company so all you
randolph you're cool
so
you've never met scott randolph but we
met one time before and you can't
remember it you don't know when you met
me when do we meet steve
i i gotta hear this one man cause it's
like i i i met you before
if it wasn't like uh we got to know each
other very well we were and there's a
photo of it that's hilarious we were in
a las vegas nightclub i want to say it
was it was 2013 so about eight years ago
there's photos of us in a booth and in
the photos i remember meeting you i
remember meeting you inside of a
nightclub wow
i forgot about that
in the photo in this booth or whatever
at this table there's me you
tom green
carrot top
chris angel right all five of us maybe
someone else i don't know dude it was
the funniest [ __ ] guess what
i got that photo too but
in one of my other phones my other old
phones did and said it was it was wow
you just bought it back bro yeah we
partied man we party party scott you
know what i'm saying in the whole night
cause
matter of fact i happened to be there
that night with chris
i was hanging out with chris that night
chris angel yeah you know yeah because
that's one of my good friends yeah i
love chris angel yes he's the best man
yeah i love me some chris bear you know
and his and his son johnny christopher
you know what i'm saying i was doing
shows with tom green cute little boy man
yeah tom green and i were double
headlining we had a little red residency
going at the riviera tom green is my boy
yeah he's a good guy tom green's a
talented rapper yes he is
yeah yeah yeah he kind of picked he kind
of picked up some of the some of the
habits
yeah now let me ask you this flame did
you ever hear about the time when i was
trying to be a rapper no
no
i never knew that i knew you was always
a jackass but not a rapper
yeah what was your album called
hard as a rock
sounds like a dick man
because these are hard as rocks
did gangsters want to be hard right and
cox want to be hard no doubt
hey hey it all coincides yeah boy right
yo i'm on the stevo show man what the
[ __ ] i'm with you steve yeah yeah steve
oh this [ __ ] is big to me bro well
thanks man and we just did your podcast
it was epic we went on for like an hour
and a half or something an hour before
and thank you for coming through showing
me some love steve man i swear man
you know and anything you need me for
bro as long as long as i got the time
for it come on man your wish is my
command i just can't do a lot of the
[ __ ] that you do yeah but you know what
maybe you'll be doing some depth of fire
[ __ ]
even with [ __ ]
yeah
that's right yeah man that [ __ ] was
crazy man seeing you getting shot in the
air in the face with it
with [ __ ] i know
[ __ ] goes inside your ear yeah then you
needed medical attention i've been
seeing your [ __ ] yeah well thank you man
and dude you look great [ __ ] 62 years
old thank you steve yeah
know what i'm saying and i ain't gonna
lie but you know i uh
got myself clean and sober now i've been
been um
i've been off drugs hard drugs and [ __ ]
for like 12 years
now you know for the cokes and all of
that stuff you know that was like 12
years ago
but you know um i've been still drinking
and i was
my hennessy smoking my cigarettes
so now it's been about a year since i've
lit a cigarette okay it's been about 10
months now since i've drank alcohol
and
not only that but my birthday that just
passed this mark this past march 16th is
the first sober birthday i've spent
since i was maybe eight years old wow
yeah so it feels good it feels good
there you know what i'm saying to be
sober man and not only that but my
business life
has gotten a lot more better now you're
saying that on your podcast
since you put down yes i put down the
alcohol and the cigarettes that's good
you know what i'm saying my business
i remember hearing you had a bunch of
chicken restaurants yeah well i had four
honestly i had four
and i ain't gonna lie but my chicken is
so slamming
i've had people come up to me and say
play this is the best chicken i ever ate
and the reason why that these
restaurants aren't up now is because of
the management they didn't do the right
thing and they didn't run the business
right
okay so if you run your business right
your business will stay successful you
don't run it right then it's going to
fail
so at least that i can
feel proud to say that my businesses
failed because of bad management not bad
food good
did i read that right that you went to
culinary school i sure did i went to
culinary school in 1978
and i got me a cooking degree
and when i went to school i learned how
to do institutional cooking
which is like baking pans of fettuccine
alfredo rice pilaf for like three and
four hundred people at one time wow
suzettes
oh man yeah i learned how to do it all
fruit soups peanut butter soup
i mean
i i did it all man you still cooked to
this day i sure do and my specialty
right now is
like we were just saying fried chicken
chicken yeah wow cause that's gonna be
my franchise you know and i s and i had
a vision that one day all of my ffcs are
going to supersede kfc's and i'm not
in competition with kfc's flavors fried
chicken fried chicken your name's fried
chicken flavored fried chicken you know
and i'm not in competition with the
colonel i'm in competition with myself i
just want to out do me
good man
so
uh
the other businesses now that the youth
center going going well
help us understand the businesses oh yo
check this out
talking about chicken i got to tell you
this story
it's crazy indeed and you know what else
is crazy the absurd amount of money i
used to waste on ridiculously overpriced
shaving products which would vibrate
have lights all of these stupid things
that made my shaving experience actually
worse
but thank god i discovered harry's which
has
second to none quality
five blade razors and it is such a
fraction of the price man no stupid
gimmicks man just top quality shaving
products and these are the only razors
that i use for well over a year now i
couldn't be more thrilled to have
partnered with harry's to let you know
about it i love these products i use
these products and i have a deal for you
that you cannot refuse because you get a
starter set with their top quality five
blade razor a weighted ergonomic handle
foaming shave gel with aloe and this
killer little travel protector for when
you're on the go
dude i'm telling you this is the best
deal that they have going and it's for
the wild ride listeners it's a 13 value
for the starter set but you get it for
just three bucks
don't be a chump anymore man overpaying
for these things
use harry's you have the best quality
stuff out there for the best price and
it's all i use and you're going to see
why when you go to harry's dot com slash
stevo
and you get this 13 value for only three
bucks one more time harrys.com
stevo for this unbelievable deal it's
the only razors i use and you'll know
why now let's talk crazy
yes i'm doing these podcasts yeah thank
you for coming just starting your
podcast it's called the favorite show
yep the flavor flavor your first guest
was mike tyson my first guest was mike
tyson but my second guess
was wolf gang puck wow
check this out
wolfgang puck
wants to challenge me to a chicken
standoff
my chicken against his chicken
and i didn't
know that over at the bel air hotel
their restaurant is wolfgang puck
restaurant
that's where i got the meat wolf gang
and that's how i was able to get them
across the street here
on my podcast
but this guy wants to
do a chicken stand off against me and he
said you know what we're going to do
this chicken stand up and we're going to
film it maybe one day we could do a
chicken called flavor puck or something
like that all right
what are you kidding me come on man let
me do a restaurant and add wolfgang
puck's name to my
red restaurant i think it's better this
is the limit size is the limit come on
wolfgang puck is the man wolfgang slave
wolfgang flay
or flame gang puck
flame gang [ __ ] yeah
yeah man but this man he has he has
restaurants and all of the casinos out
in vegas
he just built one over in dubai yeah
he's got spago here you know what i'm
saying so it was an honor for me to even
have him
ate wolfgang puck's food from a wolfgang
puck restaurant we happened to be parked
at in this van doing a podcast with
t-pain wow
and we were trying to plug in pain i
want to meet t-pain
we're trying to plug in i'm like oh dude
the restaurant i said you guys got
shrimp cocktail they said no we only
have lob lobster cocktail i said i've
never even heard a lobster cocktail but
let's get four of them right and we ate
them with t-pain they were so good we
got four more
wow
that's dope yeah super dope okay man hey
hc you like t pain yeah
was hugely influential in music t-pain
was like is is credited with bringing
autotune into the mainstream right right
but like you want to talk about
influential and music
come on flav come on dude let me get
this right because i'm an ignorant guy
but if i can understand like the 1980s
right like hip-hop just came out right
you had like the guy singing this song
like white lines
you had right
flashing the furious blondie was doing a
little rapping right blonde blondie
right you had the but with rapture
yep
percent was there the the fat boys fat
boys that's right so like at that time
with the fat boys that was like the
original human beat box yeah and the fat
boys were like it was kinda what do you
call it like
sugarcoat it a little bit it wasn't like
like real like you know like if there
was something to bridge the gap between
the fat boys and nwa
it was public enemy is that fair to say
yeah i mean well everything that you say
is fair and the reason why is because
you know who am i to call your
speculations help me understand you know
what i'm saying i'm interested let me
ask let me ask you maybe a bigger
question
like like i would consider the
the grandfather the the the
the
father of heavy metal music to be ozzy
osbourne
right there can i ask you flave are you
are you the father
of gangster rap
i'm not the father of gangster rap and
not a father and not only that but but
when it comes down to gangster rap
um
nwa like the forefathers okay
of gangsta rap and see what public enemy
did was we were more of a conscious
conscience rather i can't know what i'm
saying in the whole nine we were also
you know based
being controversial radical right you
know what i'm saying we never really you
know
talked about you know we never really
bragged and boasted about
money about gold
you know what i'm saying about girls you
know what i'm saying in a whole nine i
mess our music always had messages to it
and what what me and chuck did
was we would write about problems that
that's going on in the neighborhoods but
then within the same record we try to
come up with the solution to the
problems you know i'm saying
then
once we stopped making records for a
while
then the gangster rap was the
main thing that everybody had to listen
to
and that's what took over the airwaves
that's what
makes the rap more popular and took over
the airwaves and everything so when it
came down the gangster rap yeah man it
was you don't identify it was nwa with
the gangster rap my boy ice t
yeah you know with the gangster rap you
know i'm seeing people like that you
know what i'm saying um
lady lady lady of rage
all right you know what i'm saying you
know people like that you know what the
gangster is i think i i think i hear
that i hope it's not insulting to
to call you gangster rap no it's not
it's not at all not at all man it's not
at all i'm the first
put it this way
yeah
i'm gonna use the word [ __ ] okay
because uh cause that's
a word that i grew up using but i'm that
first
real
street [ __ ] on records okay you know
what i'm saying i'm the one that
came on records and brought out certain
words that people use today like yeah
boy
was that right which also
which that lyric right there also
made me the most
sampled voice in the history
of music no one no one else's voice has
been sampled more than flames you know i
came out with with with a saying called
carl medina
carl medina and i used that
that that word
those words in the beginning of my
record
cold lamping with flavor
right
so i remember we were all out on tour
tong
lok was in the van with us because we
had tone loc on
to on tour with us
and
tom lok says to me
yo flay
was cold medina mine
i said cole medina means it's cold
pumping no slumping it's the bag you
want to jump in i say your tone you
should put that in the record man use it
in the record
tong lok went and made a record called
funky cole medina and sold three million
copies of that [ __ ] yeah yeah
did you get any of that publishing man i
ain't want nothing from tone like all
right that's my brother all i want from
tone local success man nothing but his
friendship i love that because he's cool
people man i always dug me some tone low
man i got to go back to this gangster
thing because i find that really moving
where you where you
identify not as gangster rap but as
conscious rap and i think like
i think i see what you're saying like
nwa they're gangster rap they're talking
[ __ ] the police where public enemy is
talking about fight the power right and
and
legitimate 911 like hey we need people
to get
like to get help faster yeah yeah
we need people to stay on point mainly
like 9-1-1 for instance right you know
i'm saying because back in the days when
9-1-1 was created
that system was designed for when you
call
that's supposed to come like within
like
six minutes of that call
right you know what i'm saying and yes i
was in gangs back in my high school days
and um
we were having a gang fight
at our at our junior high school
and one of my friends
got stabbed in his side and his lung got
punctured
we dialed 9-1-1
and 9-1-1 didn't come for like i don't
know maybe
20 minutes
right by the time 911 got there
this guy already has slipped into a coma
on his way to the hospital inside the
ambulance he passed away
so that's why i came up with the that's
why we came up with the phrase 9-1-1 is
a joke
yeah you know what i'm saying in the
hall 9 and and it was it was written off
of a actual experience and that that's
correct guess what
ever since i made that record
a lot of people within the 911 business
titan tightened up the game
they tightened up their game and they
started giving people better service so
that record did help out a lot that's
good man i loved it but it wasn't to
bash 9-1-1 it was just saying to 9-1-1
step up yo come on step up step up your
game man come on man i mean people need
you man lives are important right just
like you guys lives are important right
right okay
so
the
public enemy definitely
made
hip-hop more gritty more raw more street
is that yes that part and that kind of
paved the way a little bit for the
gangster wrap to come in later no yes
that too
it did it kind of paved the way for the
gangster rap and the reason why is
because when we stopped making records
gangster rappers all that people had to
listen to
that's all that was really flowing
around that time you know what i'm
saying so
i mean you know and and you had a lot of
good gangsta rap you had something that
was bad
you know what i'm saying but you had
your choice of what you wanted to flow
with yeah
i did
um
when we were just were doing your
podcast you said something about when i
do shows what like whenever it sounded
like you said you were getting ready to
go on tour
as public enemy with chuck d
well that would be good news and you
know what i've been getting pretty good
news every morning why because i got my
whoop strap and my whoop app telling me
that the work i'm putting into making
sure i get better rest is paying off
yeah dude man this is catching on more
and more people i see wearing whoop
straps telling me how much they love
them and gosh do i love mine you know
there's the sleep i want to know right
as soon as i wake up like what's my
recovery and it's looking pretty good
today
also another metric that i get from my
whoop app is my hrv which is heart rate
variability and it turns out that that's
kind of a metric for overall health
thank god i gave up the sugar again i've
been mindful to drink more water i'm
feeling better and i'm seeing my hrv
climb man this tells me everything i
need to know about my health dude it's
the best fitness tracking device in the
world and the app that comes with it is
unbelievable plus you get the band
totally free and when you sign up for
your membership at
whoop.com
using the promo code stevo you get 15
off so join this revolution man get
involved in your health know what's
going on with your body go to woop.com
that's w-h-o-o-p
dot com use the promo code stevo get 15
off at check out with your new
membership and dude be healthy feel good
because that's what i'm doing and that's
why i look so great yeah dude now let's
talk about touring
did i hear you wrong
well
um but when i was talking about doing
show what were we talking about
we talked about a lot of things but
there was something like you said like
but it sounded like you were speaking in
the present and it just piqued my
curiosity when it comes down to doing
shows and stuff man you know i i haven't
done a show now you know in about two
and a half years because of the pandemic
came around and just [ __ ] up [ __ ]
right you know what i'm saying and one
thing that i love
doing
love doing shows bro because
me and you have something in common we
like attention we are both attention
[ __ ] yeah i love
being the center of attention but not
only do i love being a center of
attention but i love bringing smiles to
people's faces and making people sure
you know most of all outside of me just
being on a stage doing a show sure i
want to make sure that whoever paid
their money to come in to see this show
i want to make sure they're getting
their money's worth sure i'll take it a
step further when i'm performing when
i'm making content my goal is to be so
engaging to get people to be so
fascinated entertain whatever it is
that they're
focused enough on what i'm presenting
them that their problems go away right
so more than an attention [ __ ] i
actually if i had a job title that i
would give myself i would say i am a
distraction therapist i provide therapy
to people by presenting them with [ __ ]
that's so [ __ ] wild that their
problems go away because they're
distracted from their problems and
that's another thing that we have in
coincidence
yeah because there are people steve
that be having a real [ __ ] up day
inside you know what i'm saying and most
people don't like their jobs and then
soon as they see me they get excited oh
enslaved and they come up to me they get
a they they get up they get a handshake
they get a hug yeah they leave with a
picture yeah and when they leave me they
leave smiling and and and they forget
about the [ __ ] up day that they were
having right so i distracted that
yep you do the same [ __ ] steve you
distract
people you know from from from having a
bad day
making them have a good day like you
know you know what i'm trying to show
you i mean dude i'll take that a step
further i think most people don't love
their job it's sad it's true too bad for
them i love mine you know you were
asking me like why
would you do
this [ __ ] that you do and what i almost
said to you on your podcast is man you
know like ain't there's nothing that i
do there's no pain i put myself in
there's no danger i put myself in that
could ever hurt me more than if i had to
do some nine-to-five [ __ ] right
right
that's a stunt that is too far
for steve
i'm with you man they ain't not gonna
lie but i had my days and that [ __ ] man
i'm i like the life that i live dude i
got i like the job that i have yeah i
got fired from every [ __ ] job i ever
had dude i got fired from a job pizza
delivery i got fired on day one
the first day wow yeah it was like
around the corner it took me a [ __ ]
hour to find a place that was around the
corner you driving yeah and i stole the
[ __ ] bag to the person when i got
there a bag a week
like crazy i know i got fired from
another job after two days another job i
had every [ __ ] denomination of days i
have been fired from a job dude
everything that did not involve me
[ __ ] showing off like an attention
[ __ ] i got fired from and i even got
fired from some [ __ ] that i was just
being an attention or wow yeah but dude
well congratulations on the job that you
got now you know why because the only
one that can fire you is yourself yeah
because i'm the boss that's where you're
the boss dude nah man it was good to be
the boss hey it paid the course to be
the boss yeah yeah
he paid your cost i told blave about my
about my comedy when uh like dude one of
my first [ __ ] jokes i was like dudes
like that you know if any of you
remember this show called flavor of love
flavor of love like it was like a guy
[ __ ] with 30 hot chicks just banging
all of them and then throwing them all
out one by one so there's only one left
i mean it's a good situation and like
it became this phenomenon brett michaels
did it they had like this format kept
getting repeated and believe it or not
that the producers the network reached
out to me and asked me to do the same
[ __ ] format
like stevo of love flavor of stevo
and i just couldn't do it i said man
there's no way i thought to myself
there's no way i'm going to let 30
chicks tell the entire world how fast i
come and that's the only reason i didn't
do it the only reason i didn't do it
dude and i was legitimately thinking
that that really the reason
i mean dude i was just like dude i'm
gonna hook up with these chicks there's
gonna be cameras all over the [ __ ]
house they're gonna have their little
room that they're hanging and they're
all gonna be going
this way ain't gonna lie steve but hey
excitement makes that happen
excitement makes it happen and i ain't
gonna lie if you ain't too excited then
it's gonna take you longer right exactly
but if you're really excited oh you're
coming fast right believe me
trust me i already know i got eight kids
yeah but dude the potential the
potential for that show like with all
the wild like if it's like these dirty
women they're they got challenges
they're vying for stevo's love are they
willing to how much wasabi will they
snort to [ __ ] pass to to get the date
like i'd be jesus it could have been so
[ __ ] intense
i mean i don't know i didn't i didn't do
it because i know one thing i know one
thing the girls that you pick
in order for it to work with you and
that girl
they had to be just as crazy as you man
not as crazy as you it's not it's not a
match
and it wouldn't work i i'm very much in
love i'm engaged to be married
congratulations thank you and my girl
it's not that she's crazy as i am she
can just handle [ __ ] you know she gets
it you know she she can uh i wouldn't
say my girl's crazy but she can handle
crazy she's not she's not [ __ ] uh
scared of crazy and and it's pretty it's
pretty intense but dude
like
if if you don't want to be the
grandfather the father of gangster rap
now you are damn well the father of
[ __ ]
dating shows like that thank you man
thank you man yeah man i um i did my
thing i did how did that come together
dude like did someone just they just
they reached out to you like well well
it all started it all started from
when i uh
first started in reality tv and i did a
show called surreal life
oh damn that kid really likes three
right so real life three and on that
show
it was myself
my boy
jordan knight lead singer from new kids
on the block huh brigitte nelson bridget
nelson right
charo from the love boat okay and also a
young lady named ryan starr who was on
american idol but she i got booted off
okay
and everything and also um
my boy dave coulier i came from fuller
house yeah
that's my boy man i miss dave so anyway
so um once in real life me and bridget
ended up falling in love oh damn that's
right right on surreal life we ended up
falling in love and then
and then they gave me and bridget our
own tv show called strange love
yeah remember that strange love
strange first of all
okay that's a real life show that that i
fell in love with bridget on right that
show was number one
then they gave me and bridget our own
show strange love
strange love one
was number one then we did strange love
two
it was number one
then we did strange love three
which was number one
then when bridgette went
back to italy to be with her family
then
my decisions asked me they said well
flav you're printing money flame what
are you gonna do for love now i said
i don't know they said well do you watch
the bachelor i said i heard of it but
i've never really watched it they said
great we're gonna put you in the house
with with with 30 girls flav how many
girls was it i don't know if i would say
30 like as a so uh
my first
season they put me in there with 25
girls wasn't 30 it was it was 25.
and
and i had to narrow it down to one right
right they said we're going to put you
in the house with 25 girls flame and you
just got to just narrow it down to one
so i'm like okay let me see how this
works
so we shot flavor of love one that
season right there
i picked this young lady named hoops
you know what i'm saying from detroit
michigan you know what i'm saying
and and not only that but hoops
ended up with shaq for a while
you know what i'm saying in the hall 9 i
know that they're still cool i don't
think they're together now but i know
that her and shaq is still cool you know
what i'm saying but but nikki man she
was she was great you know what i'm
saying
after flavor of
of love one
which was number one yeah dude right
number three there's gotta be a level up
then we shot flavor of love too
and flavor of love 2 was my biggest
season because they put me in the house
with 25 more girls and i narrowed it all
the way down to one and i picked
delicious
right
and that was my biggest season i ended
up bringing vh1 its most viewers ever in
its history
7.5 million viewers
and vh1 has never ever seen those
numbers ever again
as we sit here and speak so i still hold
a record right now at vh1 damn but that
show was number one
then we did flavor of love three
the flavor of love three
was the number one show
so when i left vh1 i left vh1
at number one
okay so let me ask you this you had to
have had like new contracts for each
show right like surreal life he probably
had some boilerplate kind of dancing
with the stars looking contract because
everybody's like a group of celebrities
in there and then you come out of that
and say okay now we're going to give you
your own show with bridget and so that's
probably going to look a little
different of the contract because now
it's really just your show so you're
going to get taken care of i mean well
each show you're going to have different
contracts right contracts right and all
i'm saying i mean i guess they they
could throw up the bigger your audience
gets the more
you you have you you have a chance to
renegotiate right i mean in some cases
absolutely and particularly when there's
when there's crazy success you can
renegotiate we look at the jersey shore
kids there was how many of those [ __ ]
kids like like six eight and they were
each getting like a hundred grand per
episode right but now you're the you're
the one there's only one of you they're
like the 25 chicks they're they're not
really there like they've got no
leverage they're lucky to be there
they're not getting paid [ __ ] you're
getting all that money and that's after
you just did the contract for strange
loving and then you're number one there
so okay now they know you're the golden
goose so then and it's beautiful that
you're switching shows because on each
series they're going to have options
where they're going to be able to renew
you you're kind of locked into that
contract but you're changing shows you
go from surreal life to strange love and
now you're doing flavor blow you've
proven your track record by the time you
get to flavor of love to where now
you're holding all the cards so your
contract for flavor of love you gotta
have like back end [ __ ] well let's
say you produce your credit you're
getting well let me say this man and
which is real sad to say but
i didn't really have the right team
behind me
going into television you know what i'm
saying and
and and and i my contracts wasn't really
negotiated in my favor
it was it was negotiated more into vh1
and 51 minds faith
i had a meeting with 51 minds yeah like
years later down the road
and uh they told me i shouldn't say this
but here i'm just gonna i'm not gonna
say who said this but they said
that when when they they after flavor
love then they started to rock a love
with brett michaels right with brett
michaels and they also did did one with
ray j as well yeah with ray j and then
it was like daisy in love it was a
[ __ ] phenomenon right they even did
one with new york yep i love new york
they did it over and over man they they
milked that [ __ ] wow okay so i'm not
saying who it was somebody
told me that when like i think it was
the first season with brett michaels
right that before they even just when
they got there before they even started
[ __ ] filming they had they had not
started filming it but they all got to
the location they said on the first
night [ __ ] had like a foursome
he straight boned four chicks at the
same time right michaels
before they even started filming wow
wow yeah now maybe that's a rumor i
can't [ __ ]
say the source i can't forget one thing
that i loved about brett and brett
michaels he's my good friend yeah he yo
man he's real he's real people man sure
he is
and
and his favorite his famous line on that
show which was my favorite is he would
tell the girl
hey
would you stick around and let me rock
your world
love me some bread and brett loves
himself with flavor flav by going live
yeah dude he does it man you're an
american treasure bro thank you man yeah
you're an american treasure and it
breaks my heart to think that you had so
much leverage
that like that these [ __ ] jersey
shore kids could have ended up doing
better out of their tv show
like you know hey look look look look uh
snooki yeah snoopy yo she blew just give
the [ __ ] up and not only did snooki blow
the [ __ ] up or so did paulie d yeah come
on man he ended up djing all over the
world man come on man
he's the man yeah that's right he's the
man dude that's right um
but even if you didn't get the best
business
uh out of vh1 for all the number one
shows that you listed off right it's not
like you're doing bad because dude i'm
telling you that we got our wild ride
sign and i had i just picked the color i
like that i like that sign green i
picked the color color money i picked
the color green because because we were
like okay well we're going to flavor
flavor's house right now we're driving
the studio van and i'm like i didn't
know the address i'm trying to take care
of emails and [ __ ] in the back of the rv
while we're driving right and then i
kind of look up and and scott and scott
says
we're we're in bel air like we're like
just like it's like [ __ ] fresh prince
of bellerin like this and like damn this
is like mansion city i saw i looked
around we pulled into your estate and i
said yes sir i said [ __ ] flavor flav
is is
balling and this sign is gonna be green
today
no doubt no doubt man hey i love the
sign though well thank you man i love
the sign and i love going on wild rides
dude i love your studio man it's a it's
a killer land comfortable in there i
appreciate it man just kept going and
going man dude everybody just check out
stevo flava flav the flavor flavor flav
show did an original podcast man ah
so dude where
this how long have you lived here in bel
air plus this is just your second house
because you're actually right right
i actually live in vegas too as well you
know what i'm saying but uh here man
it's been like i don't know maybe
nine years now okay you know that i've
been here as well and so you see he got
this place nine years ago and if if uh
i mean the the
flavor of love show had pretty well run
its course at that point
like uh
i mean that that's a move when you're
like okay i'm gonna buy a mansion and
not beverly hills [ __ ] bell air
yeah i'm gonna buy
a mansion in bel air
like
so what motivates that move is it like
dude i'm sitting on some some loot from
vh1 like
like uh that was the chicken business
going on fire at that time yeah like
like uh public enemies like just still
bringing in money
right
like what's the biggest revenue stream
like uh that paid for this bel air
mansion is it public enemy
tv
chicken i say i say all of it combined
you know i'm saying all of it combined
man you know what i'm saying one
well
public enemy
had its own reverend we we had our own
revenue stream
you know i had my own revenue stream
with public enemy which was different
from my chicken franchise
revenue stream
you know what i'm saying
and that was a lot different from my
reality tv revenue stream you know what
i'm saying
each other so in order for me to make
this work where i am i had to just put
it all together yeah and combine it
together and i just had to just you know
spend my money wisely
yeah that's good and and to make it work
for me
right
damn so i'm sorry is here and like how
long have you had your vegas house for
um
well in vegas i've been moving from
house to house so the one that i'm
living in right now we've been in it now
for about two and a half years going on
three years
that house has to be way bigger than
this yeah yeah yeah we got a nice little
setup there
nice little setup sorry would you like
better vegas or los angeles well i love
vegas more better because
it's it's a nightlife place
you know what i'm saying and and there's
three things that i love about vegas
number one people they don't never stop
coming you know i mean i got a lot of
friends in the music industry
i got a lot of friends in the music
industry
that comes
that comes and um
you know i always go down to support
them you know when even when dougie
fresh comes into town or
when red men and method man comes into
town you know what i'm saying or
you know when bruno mars comes into town
i always go down to the shows and that's
even when salt and pepper had their
residency down there with kid and play i
always go down and i support and
everything you know you always got
people coming in and performing you know
what i'm saying so people don't never
stop coming number one
number two
the lights
don't never go out
i mean it's a 24-7
party in vegas you know and i'm from new
york
you know what i'm saying and we always
had this saying the city never sleeps
but so as
at some point new york will shut down
around four o'clock and yeah the bar's
closing everything right i was in vegas
listen
the lights don't never go out
and listen walking down the street in
new york with alcohol you're going to
get your ass arrested
come on man in vegas you could walk down
the strip
holding a long island iced tea in this
hand and a 40 ounce of old english in
this hand
asking a card to make a crack pipe and
and
not get arrested you know what i'm
saying
hey check this out number three
the drinks
don't never stop pouring
you know what i'm saying
they don't never stop pouring and and
and what i did now
was uh in the meantime between time
i went to bartending school and i got my
bartending license you know sure right
yeah so now
i'm uh i'm a certified bartender
i can pour drinks for the next four
years in las vegas
so i want to go inside of some of these
casinos man and i'll do some celebrity
guest bartending dude that's got to be
how do they not have that dude they did
not have that how the [ __ ] do they have
celebrity chefs celebrity dj vocal
celebrities ain't going out to try to
get their credentials to do this [ __ ]
i'm the first one i'm the first one and
the only one you got all the spin the
bottles [ __ ]
all that cocktails got it all right here
in my pocket man i got my i got my
credentials i'm good
i got my tam card
i love it he realizes i went to i went
to a uh uh to a bartending school called
crescent
okay and it's a gaming school too they
teach you the gaming and everything you
know teach you how to how to deal poker
and you know roulette
you know what i'm saying uh
everything's you know
blackjack all of that so so this school
is all of that in one all right i read i
read that because you mentioned the
rizza
i mean yeah you're you're you're cousins
with residents that's right that's my
weight
loss
yeah he's epic man we had to do it was
so good yes and it won't and the wu-tang
clan
i have three blood member families
that's rizza
jizza
and god bless him my cousin
odb oh damn yeah yeah but those are my
three blood members
you know my cousins and wutang clan
is my cousin
wow so are you from brownsville no i'm
from freeport long island okay you know
what i'm saying and i grew up in
roosevelt
and not only that but when i went to
roosevelt high school i also had eddie
murphy in my ninth grade english class
and then i got kicked out of roosevelt
and sent back to freeport and then
that's when a lot of
hell started breaking loose me hanging
out with the wrong crowds getting into
gangs getting locked up being in and out
of nassau county jail and all of that
you know what i'm saying but yeah and
then i ended up
um in
1990 i moved to the bronx
and i lived in the bronx on a corn on
the corner of 165th street and grand
concourse a place called the executive
towers
and i lived there for 14 years so i'm
from the yankee stadium area all right
you know what i'm saying
and then i moved out
to
the west coast in 2003
and when i came out here in 2003
i said i'm not going back to new york
until i
get on tv some kind of way i said
somebody's gonna see me out here and be
like hey flame come on
so i came out here in 2003
didn't look back man
i know
now i live
in vegas and california dude i moved to
california in 2001 from south florida
okay eddie this is this this is i feel
like this is important because we just
talked about vegas and new york
right right when i got out here i was on
i wanted to drink party sex drugs all
that [ __ ] right and and i had heard dr
dre
tell me california knows how to party
right
and then i got out here and i'm like all
[ __ ] dr dre
lied to me man california doesn't know
how to [ __ ] party california knows
how to [ __ ] shut down at two in the
morning no no [ __ ] you can't buy no
liquor you can't
like it's a you know
yeah it's a [ __ ] it's a joke i was
pissed i was busy making me go outside
to smoke my cigarettes everything shuts
down at 2am there's nothing you got to
go to someone's house this [ __ ] like
there's california on that [ __ ] guy
yeah i was gonna say that's crazy you
spoke drake because i was just over
dre's house man a week and a half ago
man oh dear bro i'm not mad drake trust
me i'm not mad i'm just kidding one of
the best people in the world man not
only that but i'm honored
for him to have me record something at
his house for his upcoming album that's
getting ready to come out unbelievable
yeah that's big to me man come on flavor
flavor on a dr dre album man
word look man that's big to me bro
that's huge dude that's huge and and you
know but but you said california you
don't know how to party
right and then you know you got
california shuts down at 2am new york
they're good till like four and in some
cases like five
you know and then there's vegas sin city
right but where i came from man i always
said dude if vegas is sin city then
miami's straight up [ __ ] hell
miami doesn't [ __ ] around dude yeah they
don't [ __ ] around vegas makes a big deal
out of it where it's like you know it's
like disneyland for adults you know like
come on
miami's just straight [ __ ] gnarly all
the time and they're not even [ __ ]
making a big deal out of it right right
right yeah i love miami though man i
love i love partying down there man they
got they got some good clubs down there
and then also i did my homeboy flow
writer
my real good friend you know what i'm
saying and uh
when i first started staying out here in
la and i was staying at a studio that my
boy devonte swing had devonte swing is
part of a group called jodeci and also
devonte is the one that did all the jody
sees music as well and he had a studio
and i used to stay at his studio and
this was before a flowrider went down to
florida and hit it big with po boy but
we used to stay together
yeah man we used to stay together me and
me and flo
and um
and then also another rapper
i i don't know if y'all can remember the
name but my boy
his name is kay solo
okay so right kay solo he had a
he was famous for a record called
spellbound okay yeah so we were all at
the studio together
you know
you know back to drake dude
like there was some when i told you
about that comedy special i made the
multimedia with all the [ __ ] crazy
stuff and i paid for everything and i
made it myself and i was like
and then i brought it and and and
everyone didn't want it like netflix
says ah no we don't want it like hbo and
all this and i was just like damn i was
thinking about how dr dre made the
chronic and he brought it around people
didn't want the chronic i was like you
know what [ __ ] these [ __ ] [ __ ]
what i made this is the [ __ ] i made
the [ __ ] chronic i mean you know i
was like let that kind of be my
inspiration i didn't [ __ ] back down i
doubled down i [ __ ] put it out of my
i couldn't be more glad that i did no
doubt yeah dude and and i was trying to
like tell them and tell that to dre you
know that i forget how how we tried to
reach out to him but uh how's he doing
man he just kind of scared dre is doing
excellent
he's he's doing excellent man i went
over to his house man my first time
ever over at his house
man's doing excellent man he can't be
doing better that's great you know what
i'm saying i mean he did have a little
fall he did have a little fall where he
was hospitalized
maybe a month and a half ago or
something like that but the man came
home and he's got a good support team
around him yeah at his house
and that's what helped him get back up
on his feet come on man that man is
doing excellent right now jerry couldn't
be doing much no better that's great man
[ __ ] yeah
and dude you couldn't be doing much
better i'm trying steve i think you're
trying to pretty much you can't be doing
much better man come on man i'm on the
stevo show
yeah
yo man i'm a big fan of you bro dude
likewise man you know what i'm saying
and i just wonder still to this day how
the [ __ ] do you make it through all of
this [ __ ] that you put yourself through
amazing dude
both of us man we've been at this for a
long [ __ ] time man and guess what we
got longer to go it ain't over we only
just begun
is my mantra that's my that's my mantra
haven't even peaked yet still building
on what i do man i have a buddy of mine
because i would tell him dude [ __ ] and
i'm kind of like [ __ ] i'm washed up
it's not working [ __ ] dude i'm like
and he was like [ __ ] that dude you
haven't even peaked yet and i didn't
believe it man but i just kept hustling
and kept hustling and then [ __ ] started
coming together and now i actually
believe my bro his name is adam javelin
oh that's not my mantra haven't even
peaked yet
you're peaking right now to me not me
and then but just keep building keep
building always going higher and man
like uh thank you so much you know so
dude i feel like you're doing fine
like uh the pandemics are over
live shows are back you're thinking
about going on tour i saw i saw on tmz
there i want to go back out on tour
again steve you know what i'm saying um
and
you know
i'm waiting on my partner chuck d to
come to the table to be on the same page
as i am i saw on tmz i saw that he was
like uh he said someone was a he he
wants to get you
back to go out on on tour again he wants
to reunite with you yeah and
and not not to reunite because we never
broke up to reunite okay it's just that
you know we it just happened you know
this pandemic came around and it stopped
us from moving for a while okay you know
what i'm saying so
you know it's time for us to just get
back together man and just you know
especially dude you got you got verses
on dree's new album yeah it might be
time
to [ __ ] sell some tickets yeah
i can't wait i mean i i don't know
until then
until then um the thing that i'm really
working on right now
is television wise all right
um um i want to bring vegas his first
late night talk show all right and
that's what i'm working on right now you
know what i'm saying and i'm real close
to the goal line right now
you know and i told these people listen
give me the football man i can score if
i score then i'll take all of the points
and spread it amongst all of us
you know i'm not going to be greedy and
keep all the points for myself
all right you know i like it man and i
don't want to stir the pot
but i got to say man i i don't know but
i didn't hear anything about chuck d
having a verse on dre's new album
me either
so i mean
so if it's time to come to the table and
get on the same page
i think the time is right yeah hopefully
that happens but dude there's no better
time
than now because now is all we got now
is the only time that we have right and
and and the only thing that we have to
look forward to are moments that's ahead
of us
anything that happened in the past it's
behind us right and there's a lot of
things that's behind us
that can't help tomorrow
but
we got to remember yesterday is
responsible for today yeah you know what
i'm saying and there's a lot of things
that we can learn today that can help us
tomorrow i love it man i love it dude
like what what a great time man yeah
it's been a good time what can we
promote for you other than your podcast
of course we already let everybody know
that everybody's gone
for me
well we did me and chuck we did release
a public enemy album
in 2020
okay
september 25th okay
and
i i told chuck d
if we release this album
you got to promise me
that we have
a new album
that comes after that that follows that
he says okay
you produce it
i said fine okay
so right now that's what i'm doing
all right i'm producing the next public
enemy album and for my first time ever
producing by myself for public enemy
i feel this project is going to be huge
and i got some heat on my album i got i
got the heat good man you know what i'm
saying and i really got me and chuck
sounding like we're supposed to sound
good man yeah you know what i'm saying
and then also i have a solo project that
i want to come with too as well my solo
my solo album all right and
and i did a song on my album with e40
and snoop it's called
og
you know what i'm saying which i think
is
going to be pretty interesting for the
world to hear [ __ ] yeah i don't know
what i'm saying and uh
yeah man so that's what i'm working on
his public enemy album my solo album and
then also my late night talk show that i
want to bring today good and you're 62
years old yes i am and i want to go for
62 more years
dude yeah man god is good man let me
tell you something there's a lot of
people that went to sleep last night
they didn't wake up like we did today
yeah but look where we are you know god
chose us to be here so i call us the
chosen ones that's right we are the
chosen ones now glad he chose us yeah
you know because that way i'm able to do
your podcast today are you able to do
mines as well yeah everyone check out
flava flav's podcast it's called the
flavor flav show his first guest was
mike tyson
like you're rising above all the noise
that's what you got to do we care about
our guests because everyone's got a
podcast we want ours to matter right he
made our podcast matter dude hey well
listen that's because
you matter well thank you you matter to
me more than your podcast i'm sorry all
right sorry to say so and i'm not trying
to diss your podcast dear i love it but
you mean way more than me than your
podcast does to me well thank you man i
appreciate that
thank you so much for even having me on
your podcast well thank you man i
appreciate that now let me ask you a
question just to wrap this up
uh
what do you call
a place
where women
who have no legs
work
a very flavorful spot i don't no where
the the place where women work who have
no legs
i don't know what it's called but it's
crawling with [ __ ]
listen
for future all of your stunts may they
all go right
just be careful man you know what i'm
saying because you're doing some
dangerous [ __ ] with your life
and you're taking a lot of pain bro yeah
i'm saying but make sure that you keep
your mouth closed when you get [ __ ] shot
in your face
keep your mouth closed you don't want no
[ __ ] in your mouth because then you'll
be talking [ __ ] oh yeah dude and don't
blow it in your ears because you got
[ __ ] for brains
[Laughter]
no doubt man but thanks for having me
thank you
you're welcome cool man
did i tell you or what man just love
that guy
and
now we're bros too
like
i'm going to shoot him a text maybe
yeah dude thank you so much for sticking
around as always
and uh
i've been talking recently about how
much crazy stuff is going down
and life is really exciting so uh thank
you for joining me on the ride it is
wild indeed